[Musique]
la cour après avoir entendu le jury
après en avoir délibéré constatant que
quatre des cinq jurés se prononce pour
la non culpabilité de daniel balavoine
acquittent celui-ci des charges qui
étaient retenues contre lui mais il ne
sera toutefois complètement acquitté que
lorsqu'il se sera acquitté d'une petite
épreuve et c'est une épreuve je ne me
dis pas pour qui c'est à dire
l'exécution capitale puisque on a parlé
luis mariano tout à l'heure daniel
balavoine qui chante le chanteur de
mexico et on achète mais attention
gendarmes
a t on à chanteix les toulousaines
le petit nez zeller chapeau on a chanté
les matériels qui vont en haleine dont
on prétend que les omelettes norvégienne
mieux du nord lé s'agit que les
américaines toit des semaines
on ouvrit tout
le soleil de mexico au sens des lignes
métro picot
[Musique]
le seul désir qui les entraîne et live
avant qu'une phrase c'est de goûter une
semaine laventure le mexique l eau
soleil de mexico mexico merci
[Musique]
c'est le soleil qui chauffent terry
n'est pas trompé tonalité mettant paris
et jean mais ça n'explique oh oui oui
mais encore merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le marché
[Musique]
ou alors c'est quoi une aventure le
mexique n inquiète avec 6 go salue la
peine une semaine
mais quelle semaine et que crescendo
quelques euros mais dans cet ordre voler
l'eau puis le désir s'est déchaîné rien
n'est vrai ne propagent au galop
on oublie tout
sous le soleil de mexico rokocoko au
monde devient fou nous vous vous fourrez
au sommet rim tropicaux congo congo
comme si vous avez un jour de la paie de
yens pied de trop de pouvoirs plaindre
le bateau allait coûter deux semaines
avant le mexicaine au soleil de mexico
et la personne en jeu
merci
voilà maintenant
cinq secondes
la boîte tiens tu recrutes léon les
ondes même pas seulement
la suivante étonnant mesdames et
messieurs
[Musique]
olé
john terry
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
et le tabac reste l'autre ou pour goûter
au bonheur de chaque jour mais où
même me permets l'eau et la mexique aux
roses maxi est bien pour la troisième
fois de la crise il est en ce moment à
quatre secondes à l'om
jason
il avait encore
[Musique]
à temps complet a atteint 7 heures à
peine une semaine c'est pas ça ce mail
et pain et tu seras toujours le paradis
des coeurs et des
[Musique]
nous allons maintenant connaître la note
du gym un adepte du juge roumain s'il
vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]